or and so now let me introduce Fred
perhaps his most important distinction
as I say is that he was previously in
America fellow but he has done one or
two other things in his illustrious
career he is the national security
columnist for slate and the author of
four books most recently the insurgents
which I think he will tell us has at
least more crossover with this new book
than some people might necessarily
imagine Fred is a Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist back in his days at the
Boston Globe and I'm very pleased to be
able to host him here today just a word
on formality shortly uneven well spread
to give a few minutes describing the
book and telling us a little bit about
what's in it then I'm going to take the
opportunity to have a conversation dig
into a little bit more of the detail and
explore some of the themes and what we
might conclude from that and then I will
open it up to the floor to give you the
opportunity to ask Fred some questions
will aim to rip wrap-up at 1:45 but
actually there was plenty of time to get
into some quite interesting conversation
so without more of a dude Fred
[Applause]
so I'm just going to speak for a few
minutes here what the subtitle of this
book is the secret history of cyber war
and when I was working on it I had the
subtitle already worked out I didn't
know what the title was going to be for
a while but somebody said well I mean
how long of the history is this because
most people think well did it start with
Stuxnet did it start with the discovery
of that 12 story why building and the
outskirts of Shanghai but no in fact it
goes back all the way to the dawn of the
Internet itself and in 1967 when the
ARPANET was about to go up that was the
precursor to the Internet that was you
know a network where all the contractors
of the Defense Department would would be
able to you know talk with Oh with one
another in their computer programs there
was a man named Willis where he was a
computer pioneer give us the head of the
computer department at the RAND
Corporation and he was also though few
knew that at the time he was on the
scientific advisory board of the NSA and
he wrote a paper it was secret at the
time it's been Declassified since it's a
fascinating document and look it up but
he said look you know here's the thing
here's the problem once you create a
computer network once you have access
from multiple SiC unsecured locations
you're going to create inherent
vulnerabilities you're not going to be
able to keep secrets anymore and so when
I was doing my research I talked with
this man named Steve Lukasik who was a
deputy director of ARPA and I said did
you read Willis where's paper because
I'm not sure we knew was near Ellison I
said well what did you think of it he
said well I took it to the guys on the
team and I got the story confirmed by a
couple people on the team and they read
it they said oh Jesus don't don't saddle
us with a security requirement too I
mean look how hard it was to do this
it's like asking the Wright brothers
that their first plane has to fly 20
miles carrying 50 passengers just let's
do this one step at a time and besides
the Russians aren't going to be able to
do this for decades
well this decades two and a half three
decades but by that time whole systems
and networks had grown up with no
provision for security whatsoever so I
this is kind of you know the bitten
Apple in the digital Garden of Eden
you know the situation created from the
very warned about and created from the
very beginning now all of this was
unnoticed until June of 1983 when Ronald
Reagan watched the movie wargames up at
Camp David they got one of the guys who
wrote it not the one who's coming here
tomorrow but the other writer his
parents were in Hollywood they were
Hollywood producers and so they knew
Ronald Reagan so he got a copy of the
film he watched it and the following
waves on a Saturday night the following
Wednesday he is back in the White House
it was a big meeting to discuss the MX
missile actually some of you might
remember that and at one point
everybody's there is National Security
Advisor some people on the hill when he
puts down these those index cards and he
says does anybody seen this movie called
wargames and nobody in it had just come
out and say launches into this very
lengthy plot description people are kind
of looking around like where's this
going you know and so he turns to the
general john Vesey who is the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff and he says
general could could something like this
really happen could somebody just break
into one of our most secure computers he
said well I would look into that mr.
president and it comes back a week later
and he says mr. president the problem is
much worse than you think and so one
year later there was a national security
decision directive signed by the
president about telecommunications and
computer security it was the first
document of its sort but it took a
strange direction it was basically
written by the NSA which was the only
agency that knew anything about
computers and the way they wrote it the
NSA would control the standards for all
computers in the United States
government military personal business
everything so there are some people on
Capitol Hill who didn't go along with
God and so they rewrote it so that
basically the NSA would have security
over dot mil and classified stuff
and the Commerce Department would have
everything else well of course the
Commerce Department didn't know anything
they have no ability to do this the NSA
had no interest in securing these
channels they were interested at that
time purely in exploiting security gaps
not in filling them so for not a decade
nothing was done about this problem and
I won't go any further I just supposed
to be just a little introduction but the
point is that these two incidents
you know Willis we're writing this paper
at the dawn of the Internet and the
extremely unlikely coincidence of Ronald
Reagan watching wargames and asking a
question that had everybody in the room
rolling their eyeballs like oh Christ
where's the old man going now led to the
systems programs and more than that the
issues the policies and the
controversies and the tensions that
persist to this very day one more little
thing about the wargames connection
before I go back down and sit down we
have a conversation this is something
that I discovered almost by accident it
turned out that the two writers of
wargames
you're probably our boss I hope I'm
assuming that you've all seen or
remember organs but basically he the kid
got paid by Matthew Broderick that's
into the NORAD computer by he has
something called demon dialing or war
dialing this is before the age of the
internet he hooks up a system that
automatically dials the phone numbers of
every every phone number in the area
code and when a modem is reached it
records what that number is and he goes
back so he breaks into the NORAD
computer like this he thinks that he's
just latched on to some new online game
and he almost starts World War 3 but the
screenwriters were puzzled they said God
is this really plausible could somebody
just it's got to be a closed system
right how could somebody from the
outside get into NORAD's number and they
lived in Santa Monica and they called
the RAND Corporation oh can we talk - oh
you want to talk - well aware so they
went in to talk
we're turned out to be a very nice guy
and they laid out the problem yeah
you're you know I designed that computer
actually I designed the software for
that computer and you're right it is a
closed system but there's always some
officer who wants to work from home on
the weekend so he leaves a port open so
you can get in so yeah if somebody
happened to dial that number to get in
he says you know the thing is the only
secure computer is a computer that
nobody can use so that's sort of the
lesson of that we've all learned since
and now I'll sit and have a conversation
thank you very much Freddie the other
link back into Walter Parks one of those
writers subsequently went on to write
another movie called sneakers which also
has Larry Lasker was and we will we will
be talking to him on Wednesday about
what his next movie is gonna be about so
we can see where the direction at this
place is going but before we get there
you've written a history of cyber war
and traditionally when people write
books about war they write about
battlefields and and people tend to
study those those battles so that they
can get a greater sense of how to fight
battles in the future to try and
appreciate strategy what what do you
think having Daniel research written
your book are the events between 1983
and now the the students of the cyber
war should look back on and you know
instead of walking the battlefield of
Gettysburg or the song sort of takers as
lessons to study for the future but
there are no battlefields to walk
unfortunately but I guess a pivotal
moment came in 1997 there was the
director the new director of the NSA at
I'm a three-star Air Force general named
Ken Minahan he had been commander of
something called the air force
information warfare Center in San
Antonio where they were doing a lot of
things about what we would now call
cyber security and cyber war he couldn't
get any of the other officers interested
at all you know back then fighting wars
was dropping bombs on people definitely
our first point of view its computer
nobody even knew how to use computers
you know and so he decided could get
anybody interested he knew about
vulnerabilities so he got permission to
do a worgen where 25 red team members in
the NSA would actually happen to all the
networks of the Defense Department oh
they had to go through a lot of lawyers
to get this done and one of the
conditions would say had to use
commercially available equipment they
couldn't use their top secrets against
stuff to to mess with domestic networks
and so they did this and they prepared
for it for a few months
scoping out the network scoping out what
they would do the people who would be
victimized were not to know about the
only people who knew about it were the
people actually doing it and the lawyers
like the Attorney General and the
Secretary of Defense so they laid two
weeks aside to do this it turned out
within four days they had happened to
all the Defense Department networks
including the National Military Command
Center which is you know how the
president communicates and sends our
orders to the Secretary of Defense
all of it just mercilessly hacked you
know sometimes they would just leave a
marker you know Kilroy Was Here
sometimes they would intercept messages
send back false messages mess up orders
people's heads were being screwed with
like you know what's going on here I
don't know what's happening there was
only one guy there was a marine out in
the Pacific who knew that something was
going on but there were no even if you
knew what was going on there was there
are no protocols what do you do about
this
so you just unplugged the computer from
the internet
and which was the smart thing to do
everybody else so and that when the
debrief happened and they go through you
know here's what we found in here and
here's some passwords we dug out of a
dumpster here and here's a tape
recording where our guy called up the
secretary and said I'm an IT guy and I
need to change passwords what's the
password for everybody and they told
them and and everything like that and
everybody was appalled and that was when
the deputy secretary of defense of the
time said okay who's in charge we need
to fix this who's in charge
and nobody wasn't sure so but then they
started to set up some warning centers
and some 24/7 Watchers which was a good
thing because within a few months
somebody start hacking into the US
military system so maybe they've been
going on longer than that but the big
thing there was something called solar
sunrise where some serious hacking I
turned out to be two kids in California
and some people somebody said oh wow
whoo it's just pure kids in California
but other people said wait a minute
two kids in California can do this what
amination state decides do this and with
a few months later they call that solar
sunrise then happened something that was
called moonlight maze which was somebody
really not just breaking into two
defense networks but persistent and kind
of looking around for things they were
looking for particular things and
eventually they traced that back to a to
a it was there was the Russians it was
using a server of the Russian Academy of
Sciences and so those were the two and
then the Chinese started doing it and
then operations actually oh by the way
one thing very interesting that this war
game which was called eligible receiver
when the NSA was inside the Defense
Department networks they noticed some
French ip's just kind of strolling
around so this was already really
happening in 1997 okay so but then there
were other things there was some sort of
proto cyber war thing it's a very big
deal was remember when
Clinton was planning to invade Haiti
because some warlord taken over and they
were they were working up were plans and
one part of it was well how do we get
into how do we get into that hid he had
a very rudimentary air defense system
but a lot of this was flying in people
he didn't like but he gets shot down so
how do we get into their defense and
this was when the sky Minahan was in San
Antonio one of his tech guys who had
probably watched wargames a lot in his
youth said you know boss I found out
that the patient air defense system was
wired into the commercial telephone
system and I know how to make all the
phones in Haiti busy at the same time so
that's how they were going to deflect it
you know defeat the air defenses of the
years later Yugoslavia Clinton's war
against Milosevic I remember the bombing
went on for weeks and weeks months and
months well there was a cyber element to
this and again it was phones but time
computers were were run by phones but
they did some of the same thing they got
into the Serbian phone system a CIA guy
went in and put in a plant and then the
NSA was able to hone in on this plan and
they rate that the air defense system
was wired through the phone system so
they were able to go in there and mess
with their radars so that on the screen
it would look like there were some
planes in the northwest but actually
they were coming from the West so they
would aim at the wrong spot they would
send messages to Milosevic cronies
saying you know we know you own this
carpet plant we're going to turn out the
lights in the copper plant and you don't
get rid of Milosevic and he said I'll
you know forget about and they would
turn out the lights and the copper in
the in the copper plant and then say
okay if you keep this up we're going to
bomb you tomorrow so he that's how
that's how the loss of the Chi lost his
cronies they were threatened by what was
called information warfare
so this was the first information
warfare campaign summer Admiral gave a
briefing a difficult word slick said
this was both a success and a failure we
only used about a 1/10 of what we could
have done but it was very interesting
and then after that you know we know
about some of the things Stuxnet there
were some things I'll give one more and
then we should maybe move to a different
step when the Israelis bombed of the
nascent Syrian reactor which really was
a sincere again we helped by North
Korean scientists what happened a lot of
people even the Syrians they didn't
acknowledge it because it meant that for
Israeli f-15s had to go about 150 miles
inside of Syrian territory without being
detected even though they had just
installed some new Russians surface
there and missiles and radar so they'd
rather not even acknowledge that it
happened what happened was that they
used the program that was developed by
the air force here and implemented by
something called unit 8200 which is an
Israeli and I say that intercepted not
the radar and not the radar screens but
a data link between the radar and the
screen so that the people looking at the
screens saw nothing the radar was
detecting planes and in fact the people
in the airplanes were hearing
bing-bing-bing-bing between being so
took a little nerve to continue but they
also had people they were able to
intercept the signal off the monitor
that the radar operators were looking at
to make sure that this worked so make
sure that they really were seeing
nothing and they were seeing nothing
so these planes got in dropped the bombs
destroyed the factory
people were saying oh ha what our
screens show nothing so that kind of
thing and I should do one more and that
is the Iraq war I wrote a book called
the insurgents David Petraeus and the
plot to change the American Way of war
where I accepted the idea this is the
only thing in this book that I'll follow
fire retract a little bit that you know
what there was a big turn around in 2007
area this is basically the surge and the
change of strategy towards
counterinsurgency staff well there's one
other thing that is the NSA gonna call
the NSA actually sent over a few year
period 6,000 analysts to Iraq 22 of them
were killed out on missions to capture
insurgent computers but they basically
did they captured the computers they got
into those systems I got into the
passwords that got into the email
connections and they did things like
they sent messages throughout their
insurgents saying ok let's meet at such
and such a place tomorrow at 4 o'clock
and there would be these special
operations forces waiting there to kill
them or they detect from drones somebody
planning a roadside bomb and then
running off used to be you could follow
them but then you had to send them the
data back to Washington and that goes to
Fort Reid then it goes back we take 16
hours within one minute they could
target these guys so within even though
in 2007 through these techniques they
killed 4,000 insurgents which is one
reason why things really kind of turned
around and I remember the first person I
asked about this and he looked a little
alarmed that I knew anything about it he
said well yeah when the histories really
got written about this this will be the
equivalent of you know breaking the
German submarine codes in world war ii
which of course wasn't revealed for four
decades after so this cyber has been a
part of these operations one of these
plans and thinking for for quite a long
time just taking you back to bill i made
one of the anecdotes you tell is the the
delegation they get sent to Moscow at
the first day it's very warmly welcomed
and yeah so they started
they never when they realize that this
was Russia and of course this was
nineties you know this is this was
halcyon days even Yeltsin post-cold-war
there are friends so they decided well
we should maybe send a delegation to
Moscow maybe they don't know that this
is going on maybe it's not the
government you know we weren't presented
as a national security or presented this
is the FBI will protect this is a
criminal investigation for which we are
saving seeking assistance from the
Russian Federation and there was a
controversy whether to do this but they
said no let's do it so they sent over
this delegation and the first day you
know caviar champagne welcome our
friends and there was this one general
in the military who was helping out they
they brought over logs and the guy
brings out his own log and is shocked
well this is terrible these bastards in
intelligence this is awful we will not
stand for this we're gonna clean this up
so then they they were gonna be there
for five or six days second day you know
we're gonna have a sightseeing tour
today we're gonna go around so they did
the sightseeing then the third day they
were gonna do some more sightseeing then
the fourth day there is nothing there
are 15 there was nothing
but can we talk to this guy well he's
busy now you know there was not so they
left the embassy is calling the legal
office and well we need to tahoe yeah we
will send you a memo on this anyway that
it's over what they realized when they
got back is that this was a government
program but this poor general who god
knows what happened to him for helping
the united states military and
intelligence guys coming over he just
didn't know and for a while the hacking
did stop but then it started again and
the Chinese started
feels very distant in time so the story
that you just told is a very military
heavy story so literally going through
one of our most recent wars in Iraq burn
and you know clearly solar sunrise moon
that Mays were targeted on the Pentagon
they led to the establishment of a new
organization Joint Task Force computer
network defense which becomes computer
network operations of years later but in
the 1990s the sort of parallel
development going on in in the White
House where people are starting to
realize the critical infrastructure is
vulnerable tell us a little bit more
about some richard clark and what he was
up to
well as all this other stuff was going
on algebra receiver and other things
well a couple years before then the
Oklahoma City bombings led to President
Clinton signed a presidential directive
on terrorism current policy on terrorism
counterterrorism and they started
setting up a joint task force on it was
called the critical infrastructure
working group because people were
thinking well you know they blew up a
federal office building and you know a
lot of people were killed in a lot of
jump well what happens of the the next
day they blow up a power gam or some
electrical facilities it says something
could could affect the entire economy so
we need to set up some some policies for
this so the working group they defined
what critical infrastructure was eight
sectors of the economy
transportation thanking and finance
waterworks dams into subway and then
they decided as most working groups like
this to create a commission presidential
aide for the Commission to look into
this well the people who are on this
working group and on this Commission
they'd had some background in black
programs and they knew about this cyber
element and they thought well you know
it's pretty obvious how you protect
something from physical damage but
there's this other thing going
this vulnerability to electronic and
computer hacking and that sort of thing
so as this report got written half of it
was about and this is where the term was
first used they talked about two types
of vulnerabilities physical
vulnerability and cyber vulnerability
and it said you know in the future
somebody could do more damage with a
keyboard than with a bomb you know that
sort of thing they were looking this is
the new nuclear weapon so that was in
1997 and of this analyst named Richard
Clark you've probably heard of since I
was sort of put in charge of this and
didn't know anything about computers
nobody did as I say and so he decided to
go do a road trip with the staffing went
out to Silicon Valley and he went to
talk to all the executives and they
learned that well you know Microsoft
knows a lot about operating systems and
the guys at Cisco know a lot about
routers and the guy said in town a lot
of bad chips but nobody knew about
anything else and they didn't know about
the vulnerabilities in the in the things
in between and so he then I don't know
how much you want me to get into this
but he basically meets up through an FBI
contact with a hacker
a hacker who is he's known as Peters
echo but who goes by the name lunch
who's like very famous in these kinds of
fields and he met him in Harvard Square
and his whole group it was called the
loft it took him to the loft it was on
the second floor of a warehouse in
Boston and they had stuff there and they
were able to do things there like hack
into any password replicate any kind of
equipment hack into anything and that
changed the whole threat model to Clark
he realized okay you guys are doing
things or are able to do things that we
in the White House have said and the
intelligence community have said only
nation-state
knew and Clark at the time whether he
was head of counterterrorism he was
chasing the sama bin Laden all over the
place room not physically but and so he
said oh this will be great for part of
my portfolio cyber terrorism because
these if these guys were terrorists they
could do acts of cyber terrorism so that
did expand the whole notion of cyber law
cyber war and and what it might result
in I think that's one thing that hasn't
panned out at least yet I don't think
there are any terrorist groups now there
are able to do quite the things that
send them the white and gray hat hackers
who who are getting paid a lot of money
to do certain things have actually done
against our infrastructure we might
think in in a moment just to why that
hasn't happened but but just before we
do this there's yet one more iteration
where we have sort of arrival of Mike
Hayden at NSA 1999 9/11 where
surveillance for want of a better word
becomes part of the story each one's a
little bit more about sort of the impact
of changes in the technology yeah that
takes us pretty much up to Snowden and
the president you know the NSA up really
up to about this time that we've been
talking about they were still very much
wedded to the analog world tapping phone
circuits intercepting radio signals and
there's something microwave emissions I
kind of think and then in the early 90s
actually a little bit before what we
were talking about they notice that you
know they have these big listening
towers and dishes all over the world
certain parts of the world nothing is
coming in anymore they're not getting
any communications because they've gone
underground they've gone to fiber optics
earlier they've gone to cellular and
they have no ability to do this and
somebody who had been director of the
NSA before wrote a paper for a
congressional a very kind of classified
congressional committee paper was called
are we going deaf and they realized no
we're focused on the wrong things and
the Cold War was ending about this time
too
so and there was the other side used to
be divided into the
a group which were the guys tracking the
Russians and the B group which was the
rest of the world but the egg replies
should this even be called the a group
shouldn't just be cut quite a lot we're
not really tracking the Russians anymore
or not so much so they and that this is
where we get a little bit into the movie
Snickers do you all remember sneakers so
Mike McConnell he was a career Navy
intelligence guy he gets into the NSA
he's looking around he's saying what
what does this big organization do the
Cold War is over we're not we're not
getting these radio signals anymore
what do we do and you know people would
come into his office with these like you
know okay Admiral you know here here's a
map of sea lanes of communication that
is he okay now here's the map you really
need to look at and there were maps of
fiber optics okay that's very
interesting but he still didn't know so
then he went to see sneakers and for
those who didn't see it it's a movie
about these hackers since 1993 and
nobody really nothing like this really
existed that much but there's a whole
kind of ridiculous plot winner they get
a car from the NSA some bad guy has a
decrypting code and they wanted to steal
the black box but it turns out the NSA
people were really the criminals and
this guy was working for the government
so they try to get it back and there's
one scene where a Ben Kingsley who's
this kind of evil mastermind who used to
be a college roommate of the lead good
guy hacker who's played by Robert
Redford is this whole monologue that he
has on the roof he goes you know Marty
war words that the feeler words now it's
not about bullets and bombs Marty it's
about the information it's about
bitching about zeros and ones about
we're no war and it ties about who has
the most information so Mike McConnell
sits up in his chair and he realizes
this is our mission statement now so he
goes back and he gets the last reel of
this film and he has everybody in the
senior executive of the NSA watch it he
tells everybody to go watch this movie
even take off the afternoon
movie this is what we're doing now he
takes one of his best field officers he
brings him back to Fort Meade creates a
job for him called the director of
information warfare and then all these
kind of nascent cyber type outfits
around the bureaucracy and the military
all of a sudden called themselves this
is when the Air Force information
warfare center with all they all is it's
information warfare is the new thing
that's where the money is that's where
it's happening but what they really did
do and then when Hayden came along they
created something called the tailored
access operations office ta o so these
were the guys who figured out how to get
into computers how to make us not deaf
anymore so to say the president says I
need to get in this guy's email they
figure out how to do it they're the ones
who break it so the new codes it's not
phones anymore it's not radio signals
it's fiber optics it's oh now they
create an air gap where they unplug
their computer from the internet how do
we cross over the air gap and there's
something created in the CIA called the
information Operations Center which it's
kind of a joint operation and they did
this in Yugoslavia the first time they
would go over and maybe plant a device
in the computer or put in a thumb drive
and with that that would insert some
malware and the NSA can can get into
them from that that's how Stuxnet
happened basically so the DAO
I mean people asked me they knew that I
was doing this book so they said what
what can I do to protect myself and I
said well luck you know look if all
you're interested in is keeping out you
know petty criminals and kids trolling
the Nets and there are things you can do
there are things you can do that are
pretty effect it's like putting a good
lock on your door you
and it's worth doing but if somebody who
really knows what he's doing
really wants something that you have and
especially if they're a nation state if
they have the resources of a nation
state there's and in fact you know the
Pentagon this is skipping ahead a little
bit but a few years ago the defense
Science Board how does a special panel
on cyber warfare and they concluded that
they talked about in one part the
inherent fragility of our architecture
it's the same thing that that Willis
where had been talking about in 1967 the
inherent fragility of our network all
these things that have been built up
over time but it's an arms race offense
keeps up with details they reported they
looked at the records of a lot of Red
Team Blue Team war games and the red
team was tasked to hack into the command
control system of a blue they always got
you they always so now the buzzwords in
forgotten circles for this they don't
talk about prevention really much in it
well I mean you do you try to you know
you don't just leave your doors open you
know you do but they're talking about
detection and resilience the important
thing is that you can detect when
somebody is hacking you really fast and
resilience
you can kick them out and then repair
what damage has been done very quickly
that's what they're talking they're
saying the game is lost on keeping
people out I mean yeah again you don't
want to give up the game but it's just
they're gonna get in they're gonna get
in and in fact like this I learned after
I wrote the book so it's not in the book
the Navy for example is now teaching
people how to use sextants to navigate
with the Stars
because they figure that the data links
to GPS might be hacked and there's a lot
of worry about because you know our
entire qualitative advantage in the
middle caring is built on things that
are networked and they can hack into
that then you know it's back to you know
m1 tanks and
sixteen rifles I mean what are we doing
so that's what people who think about
this inside the middle carrier are very
worried about one of one of the one of
the other things that that intersects
with it is is this jewel youths nature
cyberspace yeah and and which raises I
think the important question of what
this means for the nature of warfare
going forward you know if if it's all
about information and the adversary can
attack civilian systems just as easily
as military systems which may not be as
well protected what what does this mean
for you're a student of national
security
it is this a game changer well it could
be I mean you mentioned you know there
are a lot of middle vital military
networks that are unclassified don't the
transportation logistics you know
somebody once said logistic is for
logistics is for professional strategies
for amateurs yeah logistics how do you
get supplies over there how do you get
food how do you get water how do you a
lot of that is on open networks and
they've played war games where people
mess with that you know the the the air
cast orders you know they go over here
instead of over there or you know
supposedly a plane is supposed to meet
up with a refueling to play but the
refueling plane is way over here and so
it crashes into the ocean you can do a
lot of funny business with that and in a
way that you don't even know that
anything's happening so there's that
sort of thing in terms of of the
vulnerability of infrastructure which is
where all this thing we're up about you
know the idea and I don't know how much
I really buy this but the idea that you
know the scenario in some war games was
you know China is exerting pressure on
Taiwan or in the South China Sea and
they say okay you take your aircraft
carriers out of here or we're turning
off all the lights on the eastern
seaboard and maybe they do and then what
do you do
as China becomes more plugged in you
know deterrence begins to set in because
we can do the same thing to them
could be like North Korea Iran this kind
of thing they don't have anything to
hack so you know what is the response
and you can't I don't know but but
things like that can conceivably happen
and the interesting thing about civilian
infrastructure is over the past few
decades as the military's become more
aware of this they have reduced the
number of intersections between their
own networks and the outside Internet to
about 8 used to be hundreds and 52:28 so
the NSA can sit on those intersections
and they can do that legally because
they have the legal right to do this
with military installations military
networks so they can actually see when
somebody is coming over it's pretty good
civilian even civilian government there
are hundreds there are thousands of
these intersections there's no way that
you can put even at the NSA had the
legal right to do this which they don't
there's no way you could or Department
of Homeland Security which supposedly
has they've been on the statutory by the
power to do this but they they're really
out to lunch on all this stuff so
there's nobody you can do this so this
is what has led to a policy of cyber
offense quite a long time ago they they
came up with these three terms computer
network defense CMD computer network
attack CNA
and there's something in the middle
called computer network exploitation CA
now this is a twin it a dual edged sword
CNE it means you want to get inside the
other guy's Network it's kind of roam
around see what's going on now you could
say this is in fact active defense
because really the only way that I can
tell whether they're planning an attack
I have to go through their networks and
see what they're doing at the same time
it's just one step short of computer
know that you're in there all you have
to do is push a button and beep you're
attacking okay they're into our stuff
and we're into their stuff this way it's
kind of generally accepted that they can
do this and that we can do it to them
and they can do it to us to what extent
how much I don't know but one reason
they're able to do it is that for years
ever since back to this this reagan plan
and maybe three this directive and then
the the clinton plan as well they've
tried to get the critical
infrastructures which are all privately
owned to kind of you know man up on this
and get some security going the bank's
have actually done pretty well with this
because you know what our banks into
their into taking your money and making
you feel trust you know that you trust
that your money won't get lost
so there are actually some very good
information security departments within
banks and while we hear a lot about
happiness of banks there are thousands
of attempts a day unlike chase-manhattan
so not very many get it but power
companies electrical power grids you
know dams things like this they really
still aren't paying much attention
because first of all okay you've given
us some advice on what is best practices
and maybe i'll spend on ten million
dollars getting there but it seems to me
that the other guy the bad guys will
just work some way around that and then
i have to spend another ten minute and
besides you know the amount of money it
cost to do this preventively isn't that
much less than the cost to me of
cleaning it up afterwards and maybe i
can get you the government to pay for
this anyway so they have no incentives
to do it and one thing that the clark
product you and he was in the white
house
with the lay down some mandatory
security requirements for critical
infrastructure but lobbyists always
resisted this the secretaries of
Treasury and commerce always resisted it
because you know you're going to impede
R&D you're going to make their servers
slower it's going to reduce their
competitiveness oh it which is true I
mean you know these people are aren't
evil but but they have their own
self-interest in their self-interest is
contrary to what this kind of interest
is and we we've observed over the last
few years
the regulators have actually got more
interested in this space and I think it
was until I read your book they
appreciate just how far back this
tension between together DoD and the the
rest of government on exactly how not
how involved for example President Obama
President Obama just signed something
called the cybersecurity National Action
Plan which have you read the book sounds
a lot like about eight or nine other
Commission's that have been formed or
plans over the last 20 years he's done a
few things interesting in this one that
haven't been done before but one thing
he's done it's half a good idea he
created something called a an
Information Security a chief information
security officer for the whole federal
government but the thing is this guide
that there's no executive order giving
him the power so this guy it's like it's
kind of like the Director of National
Intelligence she's supposed to sit atop
all of this but he doesn't have any
authority to hire anybody or fire
anybody or said by just a real guy like
this would have the authority to go to
an agency which is just sloughing off
and they have passwords like 1 2 3 4 5
and say ok I'm taking you off the
internet until you fix that's it your
accounts are finished you're off the
internet and you have a month to fix
this but nobody has the power
you know you know one thing that several
people told me is that they learned this
is the executive branch in general maybe
some of you know this you know people go
into the executive branch and they think
oh I'm going to set policy I'm gonna
create policy well about ten percent of
it is creating policy and the other 90%
is implementing it and then going back
time and time and time to make sure it's
still implemented and this implementing
part is what has again except within the
defense realm is what has always been
lacking in this and again this is
something it's not new didn't start with
the Stuxnet it's something that has been
known on a presidential level for more
than 30 years we hosted Michael Daniel
and his White House team here a few
weeks ago too as part of the rollout and
in fairness to Michael what he would
tell you is that one reason to set up a
commissioners to sort of not necessarily
create new ideas but to take ideas that
everybody has and build bipartisan
consensus I think when it works it work
you know like this commission that I
talked about in there that really gonna
have some it back in the early 90s but
sometimes it's just a way of slopping it
off you know I think for all of us we're
rather hoping it's in this case I mean
it's a little late this thing is gonna
land on the doorstep of the next
administration in the Commission they
picked the Commission the head of the
Commission a few weeks ago I don't know
the other commissioners have been chosen
then they don't have clearances they
have to be vetted for clear they have to
find a space to work this can take
months so let's say you know they don't
land on the you know to be completed on
January 17th 2017 and and treated by the
next administration the way that
everything from the previous
administration is is treated by the next
administration which is something to you
know put your wobbly desk on top of six
at once the new administration has got
into their office and they've readjusted
their furniture with the help of
month-on-month report you arrived
present a copy of your
what lessons should they take from that
about how they should go forward what
what can they learn from from the
history that you've just read right you
know I I don't write books that have
explicit policy directives at the end I
wrote one book kind of like that but the
others but but yeah they would look at
that and well again I hope that some of
the lesson is taken from the subtitle
bit there is a long history of this this
has been going on for a very long time
and read the histories as you would case
studies and see why this actually led to
something and why this didn't lead to
anything and try to make it seem more
like like okay I think one thing you
know the thing you do need I think and
just to say just ignore the resistance
something like this you need somebody in
the executive branch who does have a lot
of power to get you need something you
know they are not called czar is now one
of the most overused words in Washington
or history energies are these the such
as they really are on top you need to
create a czar and who Riku has direct
access to the president and a president
who at least is kind of interested in
this I mean the problem is of course I
mean I don't know how these people who
work in places like the White House I
mean I I wouldn't be able to stay away
you know this kind of scheduling you've
got 20 crises hitting you every day from
30 different subjects and so and then
somebody comes and you says you know we
might have a problem with critical
infrastructure you know it's just like
what excuse me I've got people being
kidnapped and killed over here right now
your 30-year plan on the cybersecurity
yeah let's let's put that [ __ ] it's
like I've seen in all the President's
Men where they're at the editorial
meeting and one of the under says you
know Fahrenheit I think Home Rule really
might have a chance this time I think we
ought to put this on the front page yeah
well let me know as you know it still
looks very theoretical to a lot of
something distant especially and when
you have crises building up or something
has to be decided tomorrow you know it
is very difficult to focus your
attention on on something as complicated
as this and for which there doesn't seem
to be an obvious solution you know
there's something okay well yeah let's
flick the switch on it but we're that
easy then yeah we have a room full of
people who are focused on this issue and
so now is an opportunity to take some
questions so please when I call on you
identify yourselves
give your affiliation keep your
questions short end it with a question
mark
gentlemen in the
yeah can we record roll ducks a few
months back three major computer systems
Wall Street United Airlines and Wall
Street Journal all came down more or
less simultaneously I think that was
coincidental some things really are but
I think the Wall Street Journal wasn't
that the Syrian electronic army there's
something like that it's what I remember
buddy like I mean the thing is there are
now about 20 nations whose military have
explicit cyber units I mean some are
some are better than than others I don't
know how a cyber the cyber electronic
army you know is very good at like
hacking into the New York
Wall Street Journal although you know
some of them I think the New York time
is now hired fire ID than their security
so maybe it's a little harder to get it
here now so you know I don't know and I
don't know of anybody I don't know you
know another thing about you know if
somebody launches a ballistic missile at
you you can kind of trace the arc them
you can see where it came from
they're getting much better at tracking
slide but you know you're launching a
cyberattack you can hop from one place
to another to another and you can you
can disguise where you came from
ultimately they're getting better at
tracing that but it's still not a 100%
thing you know the reason why we know
that the North Koreans attacked Sony
well basically they weren't doing this
in real time because there's no reason
to but we are so infiltrated into the
North Korean computer network the going
back into the files the elite NSA
hackers could actually watch on their
monitors what the North Korean hackers
were watching on their monitors wow they
were doing that now in that case the FBI
said we have extremely high confidence
of North Korean business which is
unusually certain language in these
things and you remember a lot initially
a lot of computer experts in now I don't
either this looks more like an inside
job
you really do this but now they they
absolutely knew it that that's how
gentlemen right at the back and then
Stefan 1/2 and then I've been head so
we'll get one back first
hi my name is Ethan burger with Cogan
cybersecurity covered in center and I'm
wondering if you looked at the private
sector in terms of the stock market the
commodities exchanges set her up because
from my perception since it's just a
bunch of numbers on her screen you pre
mess up the economy of a country and
being an insider etc and if you're a
foreign power do a lot of damage to
hunters economy as I wonder if you
looked at it or if you get people who
are well it wasn't the focus of my book
but but sure yeah that's part of it and
you know one thing that's interesting
the the intelligence community knows how
to get into every foreign leaders bank
account they know where the money has
been kept they could mess with it they
have made an explicit decision in fact
there have been proposals you know
president mr. president we know we're
milazzo [ __ ] bank account is mr.
president we know we're Putin's bank
account is mr. president we know it's
about the paper and there has been a
decision made by the cabinet but no
listen we do not want to go down that
road because it can go the other way now
they did mess with the bank accounts of
Milosevic his cronies
they could do that sort of thing but
there's an explicit decision because of
the backlash they don't want it
happening to us now that does that mean
somebody could do it to us anyway I mean
look at OPM you know Office of Personnel
Management they have everybody's
personnel record
which we're not protected at all and you
know that kind of thing remember they
asked clapper about this and he said are
we what kind of retaliation are we
plotting against China for doing this
he's you know this wasn't an attack it
was it was an intelligence operation and
it's similar to certain things that we
do sometimes I don't blame them for
getting into this Deaconess way I'm
protected that way it's not like you're
attacking anything they're just getting
information
it's like intelligence but on the grand
grand scale but in terms of messing with
the stock market or voting tabulations
or ya know it's it's all out there and
open and you know we don't know what
this is this has been going on for
decades as I keep saying and there is
only now a defense Science Board panel
writing a report on cyber deterrence and
one of the things that they're trying to
do is to define what that means you know
what are you trying to determine this is
it really the government's
responsibility to deter an attack on a
bank or to banks or king banks is it
just government for somebody so how do
you define what you know what nuclear
deterrence it's pretty clear what
deterrence means cyber deterrence so
what are you trying to determine how big
an attack you know at what point there
was Robert Gates asked at one point when
you're Secretary of Defense at what
point there's an attack like this
constitute an act of war and two years
later that the the lawyers in the in the
Defense Department wrote back
well yes under certain circumstances
this crime because nobody has that
that's not it it's not a it's not an
issue for lawyers in the Pentagon to
define there is nothing and you know
with nuclear weapons there's a very very
thick red line between using nuclear
weapons and not
and that's one reason why nobody is used
in the past 60 years because you don't
know what's gonna happen afterwards but
cyber there cyber attacks going on
thousands of times a day and nobody
knows where each individual country's
cyber lyonel line of attack is I mean
the first time that a president said we
are going to retaliate against this
attack that just happened was when the
North Koreans attacked Sony over a movie
I mean who would have known a thunk
about right so there are many
opportunities for misunderstanding
miscommunication things getting out of
hand because one person's nuisance turns
out to be another person's grave
national threat and then what happens on
day two I mean nobody people I mean I
was interviewing this guy one guy pretty
high up in intelligence
he's on interviewing him a few times
before we sit down he says what you're
thinking about cyber deterrence and I
said well I mean I don't know I've been
trying to find that out nobody seems to
know because that that's a shame I I'm
on this DSB panel on cyber insurance I
thought you might want to be on it and
thinking oh my god they're considering
asking me I would never do it of course
because then it's classified
they're so desperate they're asking me
if I'm interested in joining this
defense Science Board on cyber
deterrence it's something that they just
have not thought through and part of the
reason is a for decades this has been
tied up in the NSA which you know is you
know the joke used to be that NSA stood
for no such agency is
classified and and so even when the bomb
went off in 1945 certain things about
that were classified but the general
workings and certainly the effects were
well understood and from the very
beginning you had civilian strategists
thinking about well what is what does it
mean how does this affect war
what does deterrence mean in this
context can we use these weapons in a
war who had serious people who were not
wrapped up in highly classified things
with the military thinking about this
and actually having influential thoughts
in cyber until very recently you have to
have like a TS s CI clearance to even
know about a lot of things that are
going on so there's nobody who can think
about this who is really in a position
to think about it seriously and in fact
the title of this book dark territory
I'll tell you where the title comes from
is actually a pretty good story so when
I write my books I I always say oh the
title will emerge from my notes ok never
done never no but this time it did I was
looking over my notes from an interview
with Robert Gates and he's saying that
he was talking with a lot of his
colleagues because they're good at cyber
cat song and he's thinking you know we
need to get together with the other
powers figure out some rules of the road
because you know like what kinds of
targets we can't attack you in dirt them
even the gets the darkest depths of the
Cold War there were some rules in like
Americans and Russians that they didn't
kill each other spies you know something
as simple as that just didn't happen but
there's nothing like this I mean you
would tell people you know we're we're
wandering in dark territory I said
there's the title of my book dark
territory but then I looked it up I did
a google search of dark territory maybe
what does this mean I don't want to have
some obscenity yet you know so it turns
out that this is a term of art and the
North American railroads to signify a
stretch of track that is uncovered by
signals I think wow that's just perfect
that's perfect metaphor so I wrote him
an email I said did you know this and he
said oh yeah my grandfather worked as a
stationmaster on the Santa Fe Railroad
proud Kansas for 50 years we taught
railroad terminology around the house
all the time so that's where it's a
perfect description of what's going on
except that you know the stretch is much
bigger the engineers are unknown the
consequences of a collision are far more
cataclysmic than you know two trains
running into it that is the situation
where so I have no interest in speaking
for the US government when I write to
speak I think what they would tell you
is that there are beginning to be some
element State Department is doing some
work to establish norms in relation to
the the Chinese stealing of they're
talking about setting up a forum to
discuss a process by which they can
discuss the rules of the road I mean
it's kind of that far out and but now
you know that was eight said this when
you were talking about there's Russia
there Israel is France
no how do you bring North Korea and Iran
and Syria how do you bring these guys
into this cooperative back room you know
the five families meeting you know the
bathroom someplace to discuss how to
divvy up the heroin market you know how
do you do this now it's a tough one
there's a document one of the documents
that Snowden put out something called
PPP 20 which was cyber operations policy
and it had certain things that different
departments were going to do and one of
them was precisely this year setting the
rules of the road affecting State
Department and there was a progress
report like a year later you know
pending progress report for this was
upended it's it's the hardest thing in
the world to do because the other thing
is we don't you know if you're gonna say
okay let's stay out of each other's
whatever you know electrical power
plants that means you've got to stay out
of their electrical power plants do it
how can this be verified how do you know
that they're not the one time the the
first discovery of a known intrusion
into a classified network happened in
2008 it was an operation called buckshot
Yankee and they discovered Soviet
Russian IPs and other things inside a
classified network of US Central Command
and the way they discovered this was
they were pretty confident that they had
the entrance points blocked you know and
somebody in the NSA said right now what
if somebody's already in there messing
around you know look just go and look
through the network to see if anybody's
in there and they discovered somebody in
so they had gone looking maybe still be
in so it's it's a very you know we're
talking about things where you got
zillions of lines of code there might be
malware taking up a hundred and fifty
lines of code so how do you even detect
how you detect 150 lines of code within
something that's you know millions of
lines of code it's very difficult should
you say buck true Yankee equals a
significant if for no other reason than
it leaves at least some level to the
establishment to us so I would come on
well let's hear what happened was so on
a Friday afternoon the guy in charge of
this unit called the information
assurance Directorate in the NSA which
does the defensive stuff he comes to the
director-general executives general we
have a problem there's a snake within
five minutes they come up with a sit
with a conceptual solution within 24
hours they have devised the solution
tested it and put it in motion within so
general Gates is watching this from the
Pentagon where by Monday morning people
are alerted to this and they're going
around counting the number of computers
that might be infected and he's saying
this is ridiculous
you know Here I am you know this has
been going on they don't know what to do
so he did what people had been urging
him to do for a while which is he set up
something called Cyber Command and put
the director of the NSA in charge
Sagarika Ghose
and that is when the unity of offense
and defense what happened but you know
the problem with it and you know under
the premise that offense is defense it's
the same technology it's the same and
the only company that knows how to do
this is the NSA and everybody else is
completely out to lunch on it but you
know the problem is okay so we now have
seven billion dollars being spent on
cyber they have links with all the
combatant commands they're devising war
plans they have action to get your
battle plan so you know all kinds of
attack plans tens of thousands of people
assigned to this it's you go to like the
little carey academies where's your area
of growth oh it's so cyber cyber and yet
as I was just saying of the few minutes
ago nobody knows what they're doing
there's no concept of deterrence there's
no concept of what happens on the second
day of a cyber war so you have this
whole machinery and it's all incredibly
classified this machinery growing up so
you're going way advanced in the
technology field before even the
thinnest layer of policy and strategy
have been have been really cemented on
to the foundations so that's kind of a
dangerous thing I love to thinking some
of that but I the gentleman in the
middle and then I think when I there
okay then gentlemen the widget
David Spencer Georgetown student and
army officer so what do you propose then
we do to respond to strategic level
cyber attacks and that was it
well what do you mean by strategic level
so so an actual cyber attack rather than
cyber espionage on what so strategically
or hypothetically in this situation not
not energy but another critical
infrastructure sector say transportation
well well you know one thing that's true
about our economy I mean it's not
centralized so you know if you shut down
you know the subway system in New York
it doesn't really affect much of what
goes on in Washington or in San
Francisco you know some countries have
you shut down like it's transportation
in Tokyo you've really kind of messed up
Japan but but an electrical power I mean
they are extending no grids going on
somewhat the smart grid you know which
is like stupid grid for cyber purposes
but it still it doesn't take up the
entire country but I mean you know in
some ways you know you know about SCADA
you know everything is hooked up to
computer networks no this was then for
perfectly rational reasons you know it's
cheaper you get more economies of scale
you don't have to have personnel you
have everything monitored by sensors and
it's all makes perfect sense but it's
been what speed is Oh
I can't remember what the initial
Stamper but it's basically that
everything is controlled by mice by
computer networks you know you don't
like how did Stuxnet work they didn't
shut down the centrifuges they shut down
the committed the controlled devices
that were governing how fast the
centrifuges were spinning okay so that
was that was that it was a control
device way away from there's a governing
that same thing so you can there's
something that's controlling the amount
of water going in and out again or the
amount of the looked at how not a
voltage flowing through there like a
whole lot so you don't deal with the
hardware to deal with the something in
some ways I mean you know it's like what
Willis where it says once these networks
are set up it's it's hard to come up
with a way to defend them
you know the trend in the in economics
and commerce is to make them more and
more centralized you know the company
would want to have something going out
of the entire southwest region of the
United States controlled by this one set
of you know when this was done you know
when this Commission that Clinton setup
was happening they would go talk to the
industry heads and they would say what
are you doing about security you know
the head of some train company or PPG
you need and they like looked at that
like security what what do you mean not
even thought about this so you can do
things to make these networks more
secure but more secure isn't secure and
maybe that you know the the barn doors
been open for years and the cows of all
escaped and you know I sort of starting
all over which nobody is going to do and
it's it's hard and you know it's like
when a company companies can do this
like on their company like well you know
they will be trying and so sometimes
they'll go to the government and that's
thank you what can you do to help us and
they'll say well
one thing we could do is to have the FBI
which really needs to you know say just
sitting on your network do you want us
to do that they think about it for a
minute and they say well no no not
really
well that's that's what we can offer you
a word we can give you some ideas you
know some of these things that Obama is
set up these information sharing ideas
you know here are some things that we do
we'll come in for the secret level
briefing and here's some tools that you
can use you know here's what we do over
in the Justice Department here's what we
and ya go off and do that but again you
know that that might work for six months
so it's you know this is a tough one I
did this is this is this is not a book
with a terribly happy ending it's like
the case though that does mean a couple
of decades and people start talking
about cyber Pearl Harbor and we haven't
haven't seen a devastating attack and
you you might argue that you know one of
the factors at play here is there is
some kind of deterrence but it's not
deterrence within cyberspace that's that
you know and in fact we have said the
government has said we reserve the right
to respond to a cyber attack by non
cyber means now that there is a certain
amount of deterrence and you know Russia
and China now have more of their stuff
hooked up to computer networks it the
more that this happens a kind of mutual
assured destruction thing rises up but
again that the it's the wandering and
dark territory part there is no solid
red line and that that's where things
could start to go haywire so say that's
started the frontier and work our way
back
could you wait for the people who have
online Frank Ostroff question well in
many areas us is the technology leader
everything I've seen suggests government
is slow and beelined the technology
leaders as far as you're aware as the
government done anything to create
classified or a cleanroom or some kind
of safe environment for our technology
leaders to be talking to them about what
they're working on so that the
government could be aware and leverage
that that sort of thing in some defense
industries there was something created
DSP defense security base their defense
anybody or any way they did and there
are lots of interchanges like this with
you know Lockheed Martin luckily they're
only about three big defense companies
left so it doesn't require that much but
there are things like that and you know
in recent years again that there are
information sharing systems with even
banks and other you have come in for the
brief and here's what you can do but no
and you know when Dick Clark was was the
cyber guy in the White House and Duke
has a certain authoritarian personality
you can say he wanted to control
everything and he wanted to lay down
mandatory security requirements and he
wanted to create something called the
FIB net it was basically a an internet
for critical infrastructure where there
in their internet would be hooked up to
something like the government a
government agency which would be able to
tell when they were being hacked and
they could come to the rescue but again
government I mean private industry
didn't want that and the Commerce
Department didn't want
and the Treasury Department didn't want
it so that that idea kind of went by the
wayside again it's hard you know you
have to accept the whole package and
most people don't want the whole package
which is why the NSA is you know by
statute prevented from from doing
certain things and in domestic context
unless they have a court order or a
letter signed by the Attorney General
there are some very good people I would
say even ahead of private industry in
certain respects in the NSA but again
they can't really share their stuff with
yep
ya know they're slow speaking of my
plead it was saying that Lockheed is
very slow and in a nineteen year answer
yeah so so that's I'm thinking that
they're you know if the government
should make the effort to do what I can
to make fact that innovative companies
like mine or other companies are they
make them comfortable about what they're
doing because it would be it would be
decision advantage for the US yeah but
you know then again it's we do you have
a big corporation it's hard to do that
there was this one of the hackers in my
book that's got a munch he went to work
for DARPA for about eighteen months and
he created a hundred forty projects the
most expensive of which cost a hundred
thousand dollars which did all kinds of
very interesting things in cybersecurity
he was the guy who funded that
experiment were the guy hacked into a
Jeep Cherokee to show people that hate
this is vulnerable you've got to do
something about this
but yeah it's got to be very sick I've
always thought like you know the the
Obamacare online program it's such a
mess because they gave it to an
aerospace company where the cost plus
contract when what they should have done
it's like picked like the top ten
graduates from Caltech and MIT given
them a couple hundred thousand dollars a
piece and put them in a room and say
okay here's the task go work on it that
would have been a much better way to do
government IT of any sort yeah you're
absolutely right it's it's very it's way
too bureaucratic and also it takes like
you know a couple of years to get a
system going and there's already been
three cycles of upgrading with the
offense defense cyber arms race by that
so now it's it's insane just this week a
Scott has been out in Silicon Valley and
announced the establishment of a defense
innovation Advisory Board with the
chairman of our board chairing that Eric
Schmidt so maybe
deign to get it yeah we also Wednesday
in our conference we have presented is
the Commerce Secretary Suzanne Spaulding
from DHS lead security official
specifically talking about
public-private partnerships so please
coming off that question mark broadsky
retired physicists but a lot of my
career at IBM if I look around in the
Defense Department a very vulnerable
place to attack or intercept signals
would be the drone program you would
think you know somehow those signals are
going out over the air someplace and to
be subject to fiddling with there are
any stories about that being attempted
or happening there's been rumors that
that's why certain drums attack but you
know here's the problem I think about
drugs they're very localized it's in
this one area but there is this signal
that goes from the command post in
Nevada or whatever but even so they they
would have to have I mean stocking
certain things it's not actually easy
you know they would have to have certain
things located where they could get into
this signal and in fact there are
redundant signals for this and they
change channels fairly frequently and
also how is it really worth it I mean is
it worth expending a lot of effort to
get into the signal of one drone that is
going to attack something or maybe it's
even signaling a drone that's just doing
surveillance yeah it's a it's a lot of
effort to go after one thing that's not
maybe going
much to your own interests but that's
for a localized thing if you're talking
about with any network which sounds well
for example I'll give you an idea
one one one of the early cyber war games
into the place and it was something that
was just been created at the time called
the six hundred ninth information
warfare wing and they had a little war
game where you know they're going to
hack into the command and control them
basically they did some of the things
that I was talking about which is they
messed with the air traffic orders where
you know a refueling plane was sent over
here they didn't get the water at time
is it
that kind of thing it could be done that
stuff is still very vulnerable the thing
about the the drones is that it is a
very narrow bandwidth and it's and again
they change it a lot it's to one thing
and maybe you've hacked into the signal
to this one drone that white you know
you don't even know what this drone is
doing it's kind of it just be a potshot
and then it crashes and what have you
proved maybe maybe it just happened that
that drone crack drones crash you know
happens and it's not that big a deal
because there isn't a pilot in there so
you know and they're cheap relatively
but yeah there were there were some
rumors there are a couple of things that
crashed in Iraq and somebody claimed
that we hacked that they hacked into it
but I've never seen that verified and I
don't even know if it's verifiable so
we're watching fiends sort of watching
the us watching them damages that there
could be that like what is what is this
what is this drone looking at and you
could you could hack into the field
that's possible then you could learn
things about what what the US was
interested in what kinds of things are
watching um we're burning for the time
so we're gonna grip some the last year
questions that we are asked for
questions and I'm going to be signing
books out there right fine so I'm going
to take these on this side gentlemen in
the light jacket and gentlemen the back
behind if we have time we'll take them
if not then Fred wolf happy to answer
your questions these funny words
hello market McFerrin I'm a graduate
student in at George Washington
cybersecurity you're gonna talk about it
early and you never circled back to it
um why do you think there has not been a
cyber terrorist attack of any note right
now they don't have they don't have the
ability to do it I mean again it's not
you don't need to have a Manhattan
Project you know you need to have a
roomful with some pretty adept people at
computers and the computers to do it I
don't think Isis has that I don't think
how Qaeda has that now what they there's
reports that they've been shopping
around for freelancers to do that but
maybe there are that many freelancers
who are willing to work for who can do
this who are willing to work for a
terrorist organization and you know the
intelligence community has its eyes on
on certain black hat hacker groups that
do work for bad guys you know like this
outfit Dark Soul which does stuff for
the North Koreans were operating out of
Singapore and Thailand yeah they know
pretty much what these guys are doing so
yeah but again it's not it's not
something that's inherently impossible
it's just I think that an Isis you know
they have enough money that they
actually do get a permanent foothold
something that that's something that
they could get and dusted it I think how
Qaeda is still lower early when I'm in
there when it were in their heyday so
it's not out of the question but I think
the the convergence of forces hasn't
hasn't happened yet
it's not to have a really dramatic
impact yes well I said last questions my
name is Ron Robinson I'm interested in
your opinion on the struggle between the
FBI and Apple talking about you know
industry being a head of government so I
figure okay there are there are a few
things to say I've written some columns
about this in Slate if you want made
more elaborate thoughts I think both
sides are being a little bit
disingenuous the public statements of
both sides do not really coincide with
what they're up to
well apples a little bit but FBI I think
really doesn't need the information
that's on this phone I mean they already
have the metadata remember all the
discussion of metadata like the business
records of what numbers my phone has
dialed and what numbers have dialed my
phone that's already out there that's
not in the phone they could have got
that already from Verizon or Sprint or
whoever did it that's out there and in
fact the NSA director said in an
interview that there isn't there are no
foreign numbers in the metadata they've
seemed ok so I don't know what's in this
phone that they need
if they really wanted they thought there
was something in here that we need right
now for national security purposes they
could have sent a letter to the NSA the
NSA believed it they could have gone to
the Attorney General got an order and
they could have hacked into this phone
in certain ways that did not require the
active cooperation without more they can
do there are many ways they can do this
same time Apple so I think basically
what the FBI is trying to do and I think
Apple is right about this
they are looking for a new legal
precedent that gives them authority to
do this sort of thing before
encryption gets really really hard this
new generation of encryption which is
going to make it much harder for law
enforcement and intelligence not
impossible much harder to break into
Apple ala however right when this
started happening I talked with a number
of people kind of white hat hackers and
X people in the intelligence agency and
I'm pretty convinced that there's a way
that Apple could have cooperated without
having to write a whole new operating
system which they say they were being
forced to do and that violates of First
Amendment rights
no commercial image and everything the
FBI could you know the way that this
works is as you know they don't want to
unlock the phone which Apple has done 70
times by the way so the principle of we
don't want to cooperate with this is a
little bit blown to begin with but they
want them to that there's a there's
another security feature that if you
type in 10 pass codes and they're all
wrong than all the data disappear let
the FBI could do it and talk about the
FBI offered is okay look you create a
program we don't even have to be in the
same room we'll have nothing to do with
it just change that so that the data is
erased after thousand tries 10,000 tries
then we'll come in or even you could
come in because there's commercially
available password sniffer programs that
just you know brute force in like five
thousand passwords a second you know
eventually you'll get it but we need to
have you take away this layer first I'm
told and again I'm not a computer
scientist I don't know but I am told by
even by people who are very much on
Apple side in this that there are ways
that they can make that change without
writing a whole new operating system I
think what they are concerned about is
once they succumb to this did not could
be the president the precedent for
succumbing to other things or for the
Chinese saying hey that thing that the
FBI had you do we want you to do that
with this dis eventually led to it
although I think the Chinese could do
that anyway right so I think it's a
peculiar case though for Kim Cook to
make this a big if somebody very much on
Apple side said I don't know if I could
just been quietly cooperate
because look you're talking about the
guy is dead so he has no privacy rights
you didn't know the phone San Bernardino
County owns the phone they've already
given their consent here yeah you can do
it over you can do with this for
whatever you want and we're talking
about a guy who shot up a room full of
people and has been in touch with Isis
so like for legal reasons constitutional
reasons practical reasons and political
optics this doesn't look like a great
test case for Apple some people are a
little puzzled and also you know some of
the bigger of their broad brethren in
Silicon Valley are writing amicus briefs
of the interesting to read though
because I'm not too nuts about this cuz
look here's the thing if you have a
contract with the government which Apple
doesn't but these other guys do you want
to sell an operating system to the
government say the Defense Department it
has to be vetted for security by
information assurance director to the
NSA the first Windows program that went
through this process the NSA found 1500
points of vulnerability this program now
then they helped them patch it they left
a few open you know they could get into
here later and the Microsoft knew that
and they were fine with that a few years
ago Google their Chrome system the
source code was hacked by the Chinese
and what the NSA help them repair that
problem so they know there's just been
this two-way street and I you know when
they all got when the Snowden stuff came
out and they go oh my garlic I liken it
to the scene in Casablanca where Captain
Renault says and shocked shocked it was
gambling going on here while the crew
can deliver his winnings for the night
so there's a bit of hypocrisy in this
Apple to Tim Cook it's partly his
commercial brand but he really does
believe in this very strongly in fact
somebody at NSA told me they do they
often go to the companies and they say
you know can we have a meeting to talk
about some interests of you know some
issues of mutual interest but Cook has
never had one of these meetings she's
not interested in having
so among this industry of libertarians
he is you know he is aiming for purity
although again you know I forget in fact
maybe he wasn't a chair at the time when
you when a pollutant opened up these
other second terms but the way that both
sides have elevated this battle to a
battle of principle it could end up
having seen it and then the the other
side is let's say they win the court
battle what I'm worried about is that
somebody passes a law and in fact
senator Feinstein has co-written a law
that would just require companies to
strip away their encryption if presented
with a lawful warrant now that's going a
lot farther and what the FBI wants Apple
to do in this instance so my worry is
that especially in the current climate
of terrorism and people are worried
about elections where their opponent in
the primary accuses and they're being
soft on terrorism that the backlash of
this could could be really severe so
again I'm not quite sure why he's
decided to make a a big political issue
of this as a test-case
again Wednesday we have Peter Swire a
member of the president's review group
on intelligence communications
technologies post-snowden and Michael
Barth is both featured in Fred's book
coming to debate this breeze so please
come join us
Fred final word what is the the one
thing that we should take away from your
book and the one the one thing that
people should buy this book in order to
understand it's really a lot of fun to
read
how many cyber books can you say that
about ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]